Bank of the danipa river in the face of
Ukrainian tanks hairson city was the
only Regional Capital captured by Russia
since the invasion it is now back in
Ukrainian hands and no matter what we
may rightly say Madam Deputy speaker
about the military sense in such a
withdrawal one should not underestimate
nor diminish the incredible success for
the Ukrainian armed forces in pushing
the Russians to need to withdraw in the
first place
but that success in her son Madame
Nipsey speaker is only the start of a
really long [ __ ] and hard winter cold
and wet weather will make fighting
harder but as the going gets tough the
UK will continue doing all we can to
give the ukrainians what they need with
temperatures likely to sink to as low as
-20 degrees we have responded to
Ukrainian requests for more cold weather
equipment last week the Prime Minister
announced that Ukrainian recruits
leaving the UK will be kitted out for
the extreme cold we are also providing
25 000 sets of extreme cold weather
clothing 20 000 heavy duty sleeping bags
and 150 insulated temps tents to provide
cold related to prevent cold-related
injuries and ensure troops can operate
effectively and efficiently other in
just two seconds other European allies
are doing likewise and all of that that
care for the Ukrainian Armed Forces as
they face The Bleak Midwinter is in
stark contrast with what the Russians
are providing their troops with and I
read to think what Russian families
would think would see would think if
they were to see inside their son's
husbands boyfriends fathers rucksacks
I'm grateful to the minister for giving
way
um he's right to say for the Ukrainian
forces the capture of Curson is
potentially a turning point not least
because with longer range missiles
supplied to them it may be possible to
hit Russian Navy Targets in the Black
Sea and their four begin to eliminate
the possibility of Russia using its Navy
to fire caliber cruise missiles into
Ukraine against the infrastructure that
we talked about at the beginning of this
speech is it now time for us to revisit
the supply of a longer range missiles
that at the beginning of the conflict we
ruled out
well Madam next week we keep all of
these things under review and each time
President Putin has uh ordered an
escalation within Ukraine we have looked
at what we can do to strengthen
Ukrainian capabilities the reality is is
that the gains that Ukraine has made are
down towards hair salon has brought the
ground lines of communication into
Crimea uh into range of gmrs and high
Mars systems and arguably it is a
militarily equally valuable Target set
but perhaps not quite as provocative to
be targeting those ground lines of
communication rather than necessarily
into Crimea itself although of course
ukrainians reserve the right to set
whatever targets they do and as we've
seen in recent months they have
um they have done as they need on
occasion and very successfully too
uh Madam speaker we are the largest
European provider of military material
in Ukraine and have today provided
equipment to allow Ukraine to fight back
against attacks on sea land and air the
UK has provided a variety of air defense
systems including Stormer Vehicles
fitted with star Street launchers and
hundreds of missiles these are helping
to protect Ukraine's critical National
infrastructure including its power
plants last week my right on defend the
defense secretary announced a provision
of almost a thousand surface-to-air
missiles to help counter the Russian
threat to Ukrainian infrastructure we
continue to engage with Partners all
over the world looking to buy up
whatever supplies we can find of the
weapon systems that the ukrainians need
most air defense principally amongst
them Medici speaker we must think of
more than just the Here and Now ever
one day this war will end and Ukraine
will need to be rebuilt it's power
restored roads restored Bridges
re-established the schools houses and
hospitals re-repaired
the key of school of Economics puts the
cost of direct damage to buildings and
infrastructure at some hundred and
twenty seven billion dollars already so
here too the UK is providing support for
Ukraine's early recovery through the
partnership fund for a resilient Ukraine
a 37 7 million pound multi-donor fund
that the UK belongs to through this fund
the UK alongside other countries has
already provided extensive support for
the repair of buildings as well as other
activities in the kivo blast and other
parts of Ukraine UK export Finance has
committed 3.5 billion of cover to
Ukraine for priority projects across the
infrastructure Healthcare clean energy
and security sectors and the UK is
supporting the Halo trust which so far
has demined over 16
000 square miles of land in kivo blast
so that people once more will be able to
return to the safety of their homes
agricultural land of businesses next
year the UK will host the 2023
reconstruction conference to accelerate
Ukraine's recovery from the damage
caused by Russia's Invasion Madam
Neptune speaker
the war that Russia began has now lasted
the best part of a year despite
overwhelming odds Ukraine has shown
remarkable Brazilians and I am proud
that the UK has played a major role in
helping ukrainians push back the
Invaders as we prepare for the difficult
months to come our resolve will remain
unwavering President Putin has exacted a
terrible toll on Ukraine but he
continues to make the wrong cause far
from being ground down today Ukrainian
forces are better equipped better
trained and have better morale they will
knit they will win and Putin will lose
and when he does the UK will be there as
we have been there throughout this
conflict to help Ukraine repair rebuild
and renew and its speaker I just
conclude by reflecting that thousands of
men and women from the British armed
forces have been involved in the support
of Ukraine over the co over the course
of last year they've been working
phenomenally hard often in roles that
don't catch the public eye we're very
grateful to everything that they've done
and the sacrifices that their families
have made
yeah yeah
the question is that this house has
considered a situation in Ukraine
look Pollard yeah
yeah thank you madam Deputy speaker
before I pay my uh make my remarks I'd
like to pay tribute to our armed forces
and Veterans who came together on
Remembrance Sunday yesterday I was on
Plymouth hoe yesterday morning but
wherever we were we saw a nation pause
thank those who had served and remember
those who did not come back and those
who were ever Changed by War and
conflict
we are now on day 264 into Vladimir
Putin's criminal invasion of Ukraine and
with each day it becomes clearer and
clearer that this misguided war is
failing
Putin has not achieved his objectives
indeed he is actually strengthened the
Western Alliance
and with each of his decisions he
further strengthens our resolve
the Ukrainian Liberation occursion a
region Russia had illegally occupied for
more than eight months is a testament to
the skilled bravery and fortitude of the
Ukrainian military and is the
significant blow to the Kremlin
the Ukrainian Advance comes only weeks
after a ceremony in Moscow where Putin
announced the forever annexation of
Curzon along with Russian occupied areas
of donesque glucance and zapparija
Ross's Russia's Retreat from kazon is a
significant moment in the war and the
withdrawal shines unlike on how badly
the invasion is going for Putin he's
already forcibly enlisted more than 200
000 new recruits into the Russian army
and with around a hundred thousand
Russian soldiers having been killed or
wounded since the War Began in February
the casualty rate of poorly trained
poorly equipped troops with low morale
remains catastrophic
body bags and burnt out tanks it's all
that Putin can offer his people
as the ukrainians continue to show
incredible resilience in defending their
Homeland we must continue to do all we
can to support Ukraine both now and in
the months ahead the minister will know
that on this side of the house he has
our full support for the uh the support
that the government is providing to our
friends in Ukraine and I want to put on
record our thanks to the United
Kingdom's Armed Forces not only in their
work supporting Ukraine coordinating the
supplies of military aid and
humanitarian support but also
reinforcing our allies on NATO's Eastern
flank and training Ukrainian troops here
through operation interflex
on Britain's military help to Ukraine
the government has had and will continue
to have our fullest support we welcome
the announcement made last week on the
provision of a further surface-to-air
missiles to Ukrainian forces and we
welcome the announcement of support to
protect and upgrade Ukraine civilian
infrastructure but given the parameters
of that support I wish to press the
minister ever so gently but seriously on
some of the uncertainties that are still
unclear about our support that we are
wanting to provide the UK must support
Ukraine for the long term something I
believe there's cross-party support on
but that means we must move beyond the
ad hoc announcements that have been made
by ministers about donating weapons to
be clear about a long-term strategy for
military economic and diplomatic
assistance through 2023 and Beyond
and humanitarian support
um in August the government announced
that the UK and its allies will begin to
establish a plan of action to support
Ukraine into 2023 but we still haven't
seen one
can the minister say where it is and
what is the delay in producing this plan
we're running out of 2022 so will the
report and the strategy be ready by the
end of this year what state is it in now
and is it a costed plan or just a set of
Ambitions the reason we ask those
questions is not to put the minister on
on a hook or put him in a bad place but
to press him because we want to see the
support gotten right and scrutiny and
Clarity for the United Kingdom will help
our allies to make sure they are equally
as robust in supporting Ukraine
even before the Russian tanks rolled
into Ukraine Labor's been making the
case for an updated integrated review
the defense secretary previously argued
against it but now it argues for it
which is a welcome U-turn from the the
government so I know the minister has
had a similar change of heart on this
one here and that is a welcome position
as well but the government's given
little signal as to what will be in the
integrated review refresh and how it
will be updated so I'd be grateful if
the missa could also set out what he
believes in the integrated review needs
to be updated does the review have a
clear terms of reference that can be
scrutinized can the minister tell us
which cuts to the Armed Forces he now
wants to reverse and can he tell us
where the further Army Cuts will be
halted
it was a fair question by the member for
Barnsley Central Last At Last defense
questions when he asked why is the
government pressing ahead with cuts to
our Armed Forces before the integrated
review reports what happens if the
integrated review says we need we should
have kept the capabilities and Equipment
the mod is scrambling to scrap now what
happens then
mom duty speaker it's no secret that
in-laws have been vital to the the
defense of Ukraine but the secretary of
state is yet to adequately explain
whether a new contract to replenish UK
stockpiles for In-laws has been signed
and who with in-law production will
require old production lines to be
rebuilt and restarted so if an order was
placed today can the minister tell us
how long it would be until a new end law
rolled off the production line
is it really two years away if that is
true the delay is dangerous and one that
I think the UK can ill afford
no ma'am Duty speaker I want to turn to
an area uh that is a little bit
technical but I think he's a serious one
that I don't think has been addressed
and that is the use of dual use of
technology that civilian technology that
can have a military application last
month the United States imposed a set of
new sanctions on Russia targeting a
network accused of procuring military
and dual use Technologies from U.S
manufacturers and illegally supplying
them to the Russian war machine
rusi at the UK defense Think Tank
confirmed in August of this year that UK
components are appearing in Russian
Weaponry that can include oscillators
and standard crystals now no UK produced
equipment should end up in the hands of
Putin and his generals and this is
especially difficult though to be sure
of when it comes to dual use equipment
this house has already passed sanctions
on Dual use equipment but the concern is
that Western electronics and
Technologies are still reaching Russian
weapon manufacturers
this will be concerning to colleagues so
we need Clarity that British firms are
not in good faith making materials or
contributing to the supply chain of
Western manufacturers whose end product
could end up killing Ukrainian civilians
so can I ask the minister what steps the
government is taking to identify dual
use technologies that could be used by
Putin and what steps is he taking to
stop those Technologies getting into the
hands of Russia or their agents
does he feel that the current dual use
sanctions are sufficient and what steps
can he take working with our allies to
Monitor and shut off possible purchasing
routes for Russia of Western dual use
equipment like gyroscopes Wi-Fi
technology ceramic chips resistors and
semiconductors I realize this is the
complex area and I realized I put the
minister on the spot here for for uh for
his colleague from the foreign office to
reply to and so be grateful if the
minister can't set out this now whether
he could put a letter in the House of
Commons Library this is a difficult area
but one that we must make sure that
we're getting right
Manchester speaker we know that since
the War Began Russian troops have been
committing atrocities against Ukrainian
civilians
isium and marry upole there is now
evidence of Russian war crimes in the
kurzon region
we will not know for some time how many
civilians the Russians have butchered
but we must be unrelenting in our
pursuit of these war criminals until
each and every one of them has stood
trial for their crimes
as ukrainians face the arrival of winter
it's becoming increasingly clear that
Putin's strategy is to Target civilian
infrastructure including energy and
water plants the minister has set out
some support that the UK government is
providing but can he also set out what
additional missile defense the UK is
providing to our allies to protect
Ukrainian infrastructure from missile
attacks by Russia and what plans he has
to deal with the potential for
additional flow of cold and hungry
refugees this winter because the effect
of Russian bombardment of Civilian
infrastructure is already degrading the
ability of Ukraine to provide clean
water and power to all its population
and that will drive a further
humanitarian crisis
speaker I want to briefing downtown turn
to how we can afford the defense of the
UK and our allies in Ukraine we know the
government's disastrous mini budget has
cost 30 billion which is the equivalent
of 60 of the UK's current defense budget
and that sheer amount of money could
have been better spent on hospitals
teachers and the cost of living crisis
but in defense terms that's the cost of
23 brand new type 26 frigates it's a
huge amount of money
that has been
abused by the government
the mod is the only government
Department in the current spending round
with the real terms Revenue cut each
year
new ifs figures show that adjusted for
inflation that's a 2.7 billion real
terms cut to defense spending
at the defense select committee last
week the sector of State for defense has
said with the additional defense
inflation that's 8 billion additional
costs he has to his budget
if we are to continue to provide the
support to Ukraine and continue to make
sure that we can afford an enhance
forward presence for our NATO allies and
our other NATO commitments we need to
have certainty that the funding will be
available as required for our Armed
Forces
to speak I've been re-reading the rather
good defense select committee report
called Shifting the goal posts which
shows that labor governments have always
spent more on our nation's defense than
conservative governments does the
commitment to raise defense spending to
three percent of GDP by 2030 still exist
can the minister see a point where
defense spending for this government
Falls below the two percent GDP NATO
Target and given their previous comments
on defense spending can the minister say
whether he and the secretary of state
will still be in their places if defense
spending is cut in the Chancellor's
Autumn statement on Thursday
spending this may I don't believe this
has come up yet in this debate but
clearly Putin is using propaganda as a
serious weapon in this battle and one
that I think we all have an interest in
countering and so it'll be helpful
um if the minister in and the government
in there somebody got comments could
give some reassurance that UK is
committed to the counter disinformation
unit and are working in collaboration
with the foreign Commonwealth
development office to ensure that we
play our part in ensuring this
propaganda does not win in Ukraine and
does not win elsewhere either yeah
yeah I think my um almost Frank from
Newcastle for her intervention I think
she is right Putin has invested heavily
in disinformation Technologies and in
resources to spread misinformation and
disinformation in the news feeds on
social media right across the world
including here in the United Kingdom
that investment was not made on a whim
it was made against a clear strategy
that says they wish to divide split and
misinform Western populations to use our
democracy against us and we must be
absolutely determined to protect our
democracy and to protect our allies that
we tackle this information
misinformation and those dark cyber
activities online we're not just talking
about
state-sponsored hacking and cyber
attacks although that is one end of the
spectrum we're talking about all the our
constituents seeing things on their
Facebook news feeds which are
deliberately deployed and shared to try
and split and degrade public opinion to
uh to create the impression that the
United Kingdom support for our friends
in Ukraine is somehow uh coming from a
dark place when it is not and that means
further action to strengthen our work on
social media it means looking at where
Russia is investing in this information
and it means looking at how we can
strengthen our civil society against
that in the future and I hope that the
minister and his colleagues that are
looking after the Online safety bill for
instance will take that seriously as
well because this is not just military
grade activity we do look at this is
everything through to how each of us
uses our social media now Madame Deputy
speaker in conclusion I want there to be
no doubt
now on this side of the house we share
the resolve of the government
supporting Ukraine for as long as is
necessary to defeat Putin
but as the Ukrainian Countryside turns
to mud and then freezes over
we're about to enter an incredibly
difficult winter
where military Doctrine normally
suggests
that front lines are frozen
and civilian populations suffer further
the ukrainians are showing incredible
resolve in standing up to Russia but
they can't do that without continued
Western support
so how we use the winter months
to ensure that our our supply lines our
commitment our resolved and our
Technologies
are available to our friends in Ukraine
will be as important as it will be for
the ukrainians
because as uh because how we use the
winter months to prepare for the
expected spring offensives will be
crucial in keeping the pressure firmly
on the Kremlin and ensuring Ukraine wins
thank you
Jonathan thank you speaker as we Rejoice
at the liberation of her song we need to
be mindful that Ukraine is still very
much a country at War there's Russian
Federation tanks rolled across the
border onto Sovereign Ukraine territory
on the 24th of February the world for a
witness to an attack against the
post-second world war settlement of a
magnitude and a kind without precedent
and I congratulate the government on the
superb and consistent support that the
UK has provided to Ukraine but the
situation constantly changes and I
believe that we now need a rethink on
sanctions
I frequently hear people including UK
ministers saying that this is Putin's
War not that of the Russian people
thereby laying the blame of an entire
nation's aggression at the feet of one
man
this is an aggression we must not forget
that seeks to erase Ukraine from the map
destroy its culture turn back the clock
to a period when the russia-centric
Soviet Union dominated Eastern Europe
and its peoples
having had the opportunity to visit
Ukraine most recently in September and
speak with some of the brave men and
women valiantly defending their Homeland
the notion that this is solely Putin's
war is one that I would now reject of
course
Western induced regime change within the
Russian Federation is not a sound basis
for the United Kingdom's foreign policy
but even if it were I do not believe
that the idea mooted my son that new
leadership in Moscow would necessarily
bring the war to an end
in fact I believe the opposite to be
possible with a new leader trying to
burnish their nationalistic credentials
by taking even greater destructive and
indiscriminate military action in effect
no Putin does not necessarily equate to
no War I give way
grateful to um The Honorable member for
giving way it was a pleasure to be with
him in Kiev earlier this year he's
making an incredibly important point
because sometimes we hear our allies say
we have to make sure that Putin can't do
this again actually that is the wrong
analysis we have to make sure that
Russia cannot do this again
The Honorable gentleman's absolutely
you're right right on broadens
absolutely right and I'm going to
um try and prove that point somewhat
further because many of those in
leadership roles that surround the
current Russian president such as the
chechnya leader kadarov who has
suggested of course using a tactical
nuclear weapon against Ukraine their
spouse rigid nationalist views and they
should not and cannot be absolved from
blame for the evasion as the term
Putin's War may allow
it is also important to highlight that
many towns in reoccupied Ukraine now
have unmarked Graves resulting from
murders perpetrated by members of the
Russian Armed Forces with the Buca
Massacre appointed example that we all
have a duty to remember and reflect upon
reports are also Rife of mass rapes
looting torture removal of children and
confiscation of vital foodstuffs again
all Deeds Done by soldiers and
administrators of the occupying power
and it's clear to me that many people of
the Russian Federation are up to their
necks in heinous crimes committed during
the ongoing war against the Ukrainian
people and the individual perpetrators
must Bear full responsibility for this
and of course be prosecuted
so a case against those actively engaged
in The Invasion is clear but what about
the wider Russian people themselves
the problem is that by using the term
Putin's War it's possible to excuse
Overlook or ignore that the war in all
its Gore and Injustice remains very
popular amongst most of the Russian
population and it's not not just Putin
and his crime is and his oligarchs some
Russians a small minority have laudably
taken a stand memorably and notably
Marina
osteocadnikova whose staged an on-air
protest in March announcing the war such
Defiance has however been more of an
exception than the rule indeed polling
from within the Russian Federation
continues to indicate strong support of
over 70 for both the war and Putin
amongst its populace
I think I Thank The Honorable member for
coming around to making an excellent
speech as ever I mean it is a complex
issue the extent to which the Russians
support this war and he's not wrong to
say what he said that it is still very
popular I just wonder if a slightly more
generous way of putting it is that there
is a hardcore against very brave people
as his outline there is a hardcore for
the military bloggers the Nationalist
Community who are becoming increasingly
concerned but in the last 20 years
because of the amount of propaganda in
the Russian Society most Russians know
to avoid Politics as an issue because
you let the people in power get on with
things and so I'm not neces I don't
think it's not so much popularity of the
war as as a sense of agnosticism towards
politics and a sense of keeping away
from it as a subject would he accept
that point well I accept that it's it's
a subject that we could go into in some
in some degree but I would make the
point that of those Russians that have
been leaving Russia and going to places
like Armenia or or Georgia or over 250
000 to Turkey It Is by no mean proven
that they are anti-putin in fact in fact
a lot of research does they go into
these countries because they either want
to uh pursue their business activities
and can't become sanctions or because
they don't want to be called up on on
the reserve list and so they leave not
because they don't like President Putin
so what I'm suggesting here is that at
some point systems and leaders need to
take Collective responsibility for the
actions of the state and on forces that
operate in their name for Russians I
would argue that that time has long
passed and if we agree that there should
be Collective responsibility then we can
make the moral case for Collective
sanctions economic and travel travel
restrictions like those implemented by
six EU states are important as they
practically reinforce the message of
collective responsibility compared to
economic sanctions which will mainly
apply only to wealthier people
as the situation currently stands at the
end of the war whenever that may be or
indeed before frozen assets across the
west and other areas of the globe that
have been sanctioned including here in
the United Kingdom will be reclaimed by
their owners
the public including many constituents
in Huntington that I have corresponded
with about the situation in Ukraine
naturally assume that a frozen super
yacht owned by a sanctioned individual
will be solved with the proceeds used
for reconstruction
we're talking here of some 18 billion
pounds of frozen assets not including
real estate in the UK alone
this is not alas currently the case
and if the situation is not remedied I
believe an embarrassing political
situation not to mention a morally
dubious one beckons
so I think ministers should be prepared
to consider working with our allies how
frozen assets can be legally seized sold
and the revenue put to work for
Ukraine's rebuilding the world bank's
assessment made in September is that
Ukraine will need
349 billion dollars for recovery and
reconstruction but I think it's worth
saying that it's not just a question of
Law changes it's also about adopting a
more aggressive attitude within the
existing system
for instance when the FBI boarded the
sanctions Mr karimos yacht amadea in
Fiji it looks like they
the United States use the oligarchs
maintenance of the yacht as a criminal
breach of sanctions which thereby
allowed confiscation of the yacht we
could and should also be more assertive
than we are
as for the possible Law changes to
facilitate facilitate the confiscation
the first is a revisiting of the trading
with the Enemy Act of 1939. during the
second world war this act allowed the
government of the day to confiscate
assets owned by residents of enemy
countries and British territories the
ACT focuses squarely on the assets of
any person or organization of countries
the United Kingdom is at war with and
thankfully there has not obviously been
much coarse for review it since 1945.
however an amendment to the definition
of War could provide a valuable basis
for considering how Russian assets could
be seized to the benefit of Ukraine and
its reconstruction
secondly I refer to Canada's budget
implementation Act passed in June of
this year which includes amendments that
allow for the forfeiture of property
that is subject to a seizure or
restraint order under the special
economic measures act and their Justice
for victims of corrupt foreign officials
acts their Sergey majnesky legislation
this is done under both regimes using
forfeiture orders allowing the relevant
minister of the Canadian government to
apply to a court to Forfeit assets that
have already been seized or Frozen
a number of safeguards are rightly built
into the legislation so for instance any
person who appears to have an interest
in the property may be heard by the
relevant Court
a further possible Avenue that I wish to
highlight is one proposed by the
Washington dc-based new lines Institute
for stration policy who formulated a
multilateral action models model on
reparations in this model
The Institute draws 13 convincing
conclusions which lay the basis for an
international effective and legal
reparations and compensation scheme the
model Builds on the recent relatively
recent and practical example of the Q8
compensation fund which together with
the UN compensation commission pays some
52 billion dollars in conversation to
one and a half million claimants over 30
years following the Iraqi invasion in
1990. the establishment of the funding
commission was only possible due to
agreement of those nations with a
permanent seat at the U.N security
Council and of course as an aggressor in
Ukraine's in Ukraine as a rasterism
aggressor in Ukraine's case its exact
romac cannot unfortunately be followed
however
Instead The Institute makes the argument
of for working through the U.N General
Assembly instead of the security Council
Madam Deputy speaker these avenues that
I've highlighted today are but a number
that I think are worthy of wider
consideration there are others well it's
crucial however is that the conversation
surrounding compensation and reparations
now begins in Earnest because just to
continue saying that these this is only
Putin's war is no longer relevant or
morally sustainable
SMP spokesman Martin Doherty Hughes
thank you madam Deputy speaker let me
first of all associate myself with the
words of the minister in relation to
2014 supporting the men and women of the
Ukrainian armed forces in terms of
training and also the shadow minister in
terms of remembrance Sunday I'm very
mindful of my own brother who is a
veteran from Iraq and Afghanistan
actually for the very first time
attended the cenotaph in Whitehall at
the weekend with former comrades I have
to say it is indeed man of Deputy
speaker uh welcome to be standing here
following the statement about liberation
of her son and like so many people it's
been a joy to watch the videos and
accounts over the weekend of the
Liberation there is though unfortunately
a pattern in this conflict of the
Elation after these liberations of towns
and Villages being followed by the
revulsion and anger as we discover the
Litany of crimes committed by Russian
armed forces and administrators during
their occupation now I have to say
eyeshadow to think what would happen to
those who were brave enough to resist
that Invasion during the early days of
February so memory caught on camera for
the world to see
nonetheless forcing this invading Force
off the West Bank of nipra should be
celebrated for the Triumph that it is
along with the liberation of the last
remaining Regional Capital under a nude
occupation now the decision of the
retreating forces to blow Bridges among
the lines of the withdrawal demonstrates
the Direction They believe the conflict
to be moving in though we must hope that
it can move as quickly as possible in
the direction to avoid Kirsten facing
the same sort of Retribution that Russia
has visited on the lakes or here cave
and nuclear
there's such targeting and destroying of
Civilian infrastructure has become a
such a certainly true Russian military
handbook again demonstrates the weakness
of their position
and the repeated inability to abide by
the key tenants I think the whole house
will agree of the Geneva Convention
itself namely their failure to avoid
unnecessary suffering and the failing to
distinguish between civilians Madame
Deputy speaker and combatants it is a
damning indictment of their
which they claim to be defending as
you're ever likely to see now I'm sure
the minister and others across the house
will join me in beseeching the Russian
Federation to withdraw from the rest of
the country which they have illegally
occupied since 2014 to avoid the
suffering from continuing
The Liberation of such a large part Port
also brings into Focus I think the
minister touched on it uh when they
opened up the debate but the global
consequences of continuing this
unnecessary conflict not only because he
has done its famous watermelons can now
be exported but as a whole host of other
agricultural products of Ukraine's
famous black soil too
these grains and vegetable oils have
been effectively held hostage by the
creme by Vladimir Putin as a part of a
strategy of resource terrorism
seeking to punish some of the poorest
people in the world as a way of putting
pressure on those who would support
Ukraine as the G20 Summit actually comes
to a close Madame Deputy speaker over
Charlotte by this coercive diplomacy I'm
sure we can all agree that we hope that
this is not the issue the same issue uh
come the next summer
and as we talk about exports we have to
also think about the health of the
Ukrainian economy as a whole and let's
not forget the importance of providing
again as the minister mentioned the
long-term economic guarantees to Ukraine
that can ensure that it's able to
rebuild when the end of the conflict
comes as it must
the incredible potential that has had to
be unable to be fully realized can only
be released with a generous range of
measures and with a full integration
into the Western economic networks as
also Ukraine would wish including the
European Union
however regardless of the military and
economic support we give Ukraine and its
people we cannot forget the human
element in all of us and it's the fact
that these are people who are fighting
so much so much more than just for
economic growth or european security
they are fighting simply for the right
to exist
that is the right to exist Madam Deputy
speaker as ukrainians but it's also a
right to exist as the people who they
are and I have to say I'm glad to be
able to get the opportunity to
acknowledge the contribution made by the
lgbtq Plus ukrainians in this conflict
their struggle I would say is emblematic
of what is at stake here normally
because Putin and other Kremlin Talking
Heads have specifically made their
increasing prominence in that Society a
major plank of their spurious rationale
for invasion
we know very well in this country that
the realities of wartime Society can
bring about
large-scale social change as previously
underrepresented people groups
represented groups of Society come
forward to demonstrate the role that
they can play in society so through this
conflict they'll be seeing how lgbtq
Plus ukrainians have come forward and
served in their droves at every level
commonly known as The Pride Brigade and
I'm very much grateful for the work done
by people like Maxi mirstrid who has
donated a documented the contribution
these ukrainians have made to the
defense of their common Homeland and
there is indeed evidence that it's
changing Ukrainian Society I believe for
the better
thanks to Maxie I found out this summer
that almost 60 of ukrainians now have a
more positive attitude to their lgbtq
plus siblings a massive increase since
2016 when they were last asked the
question
these are people who know what it is
that they are fighting for for the
possibility to live in a country where
they are free from the types of
dystopian control and coercion that we
are now seeing too often in Putin's
Russia so let me bring my remarks to an
end Madam Deputy speaker by thanking the
ministers and indeed the government who
are continuing to ensure that Ukraine
can continue to push these Invaders out
of their country they can be assured the
support from everyone on these benches
and I think essentially everyone across
the house and making sure that it
continues to be the case here's hoping
we'll be marking the liberation of
Ukraine sooner rather than later
Bob Sealy thank you very much Deputy
speaker
um I won't
um try The house's patience for too long
I just want to make some general points
um and I think the minister is
completely right when he says
um that it is a very very important
victory that her son victory was
enormously important regardless of
whether it was a a military a
significant military or um insignificant
in military terms or significant
symbolically and he obviously makes a
point that it's difficult to invade a
country if you're going backwards and we
can all agree with that I would say
although it is symbolically Dreadful it
is not yet a military Game Changer and I
think the Russian strategy just to build
on the question I asked a bit earlier I
think the Russian strategy at the moment
seems to be too prone firstly surovican
who's with his Syrian experience has
said to the Russian Ministry of Defense
give me a line that I can hold and her
son because it was on the Western Bank
of the benipro her son was simply not
holdable it was a death track and it was
a disaster waiting for the Russian
military
so sarovicum by pulling out of her son
City and pulling over to the Eastern
Bank of the danipra has effectively got
the nanipra river between him and the
ukrainians and for those I lived in
Ukraine from 90 to 95 and for those
people who know their geography in
Ukraine the the River danipra from south
of her son all the way up to zaparosia
at its thinnest it's half a kilometer if
you add the
um the water Banks if you had the
conquer River the river conquer if you
add the Marshland if you add open
grassland it is a minimum of three
kilometers wide if you go up to
zaparosia where the nuclear power plant
is it's more of a lake and it's about 10
to 12 kilometers wide so sarovicum by
moving his forces to the Eastern Bank of
the denipro has effectively got the
denipro as a very considerable buffer
between him and the Ukrainian forces and
realistically any Ukrainian Advance is
not going to happen is not going to take
place south of zaparosia because simply
the geography I mean you might as well
try to you know cross the channel uh you
cannot do it without phenomenal
resources and you're going across
significant open territory and the
casualty rate even against the Russian
forces disorganized and demoralized as
this would simply be not acceptable it
would fail and be a significant counter
um against the ukrainians so that's the
first sir Rubicon has said firstly I
need a defensible line and getting the
danipra the right side of him he now has
a defensible line all the way up to
zaparosa the second thing I think
ceramicin has done and again for those
of us who sadly followed him in Syria
this is par for the cause he's
prioritized the destruction of Civilian
morale now in Syria one of the really
awful and depressing things was the way
that the syrians and the Russians who
are one of the five permanent members of
the security Council was that the
syrians and the Russians the Russian the
Russian backers
prioritize the destruction of Civilian
targets and most importantly and most
tragically and I talked to many Syrian
doctors about this uh was that the
Russians targeted the destruction of
hospitals
because by destroying hospitals first
you destroyed popular morale the men
would fight as long as their women and
their families would stay
not for that to happen you needed some
kind of food supply and you needed
hospitals but to destroy the hospitals
meant that the women and children fled
and without the women and children the
men effectively were pulled back as well
and so by destroying civilian
infrastructure you destroy morale the
other thing noticeably and it is
important for this debate that the
Russians did or the syrians with their
Russian backers did for four years
Aleppo Aleppo was bombed and for four
years Aleppo survived and civilian life
in bizarre and horrendous circumstances
continued
the syrians and their Russian backers
use chemical weapons for 17 days and
they cleared the city
so actually it wasn't despite four years
of bombardment what
and despite actually the attacks on the
hospitals which took a few months to
clear civilian populations what cleared
it pretty much overnight was the use of
chemical weapons and I say that now
because the Russians are still talking
about making accusations about
bioterrorism against ukrainians and
against Americans and there's still as
we know talking about nuclear and I'll
come on to that in a second so there is
still they are still the Russians are
still holding out the option of using
chemical and nuclear weapons and one
should not simply dismiss this as Bluff
because we don't know it's Bluff because
we cannot tell therefore it is not just
Bluff it may well be but we do not know
so those are the two pronged attacks the
two the two prongs of Russian strategy
get a defensible line or you a line
that's you think is defensible and
Destroy civilian infrastructure and
behind that I mean the actually if you
go back to it the current phase of this
war started back I think in September
when I was in Ukraine I think with the
right honorable several right-honorable
uh members who are here it's good to see
them and in fact we saw zelinsky on that
Sunday and they were just Overjoyed
because you had the collapse of Hawking
positions uh and and we were there as it
was happening
um that was the beginning of the new
phase because it was a phase of the war
where we realized the Russians realize
actually we can't win and it was the
phase it was that weekend that the
ukrainians thought actually we can win
this war
and I think that was a very very
important moment
the next so the Russians Now by having a
defensive line and attacking civilian
infrastructure they bought some time
they probably bought themselves a few
months
the next phase of the war is going to
take place probably in the spring
when the Russian positions come under
significant pressure and they will come
under significant pressure of my
understanding of what's happening is
correct in the South between zaparosia
and danetsk or in the East between and
against around the legansk area and it
may be that the the ukrainians try a
faked the South Wall attacking donbass
because that's where their best armor is
but either way the new phase when it
happens with a string a spring offensive
or potential late winter offensive that
will be uh what we will witness if we do
witness it will be the cracks of Russian
positions and the critical point here is
not necessarily defeating Don bass which
will be great for the ukrainians but the
critical point for the strategy in the
war will be the collapse of the line
Corridor between Crimea and donets and
if that happens it is then the beginning
of the end for the Russians
because they can continue to hold the
area of donbass They seized in 2014 not
going to make much difference they could
potentially still keep hold of Crimea
which I think will be the last to go but
the destruction of the land Corridor
means the final defeat and the the we're
entering then the end game it will be
beginning of the end for Russian forces
if that land Corridor goes and at that
point Putin has a series of very very
important decision points to use a
military term does it go nuclear does he
not does he use chemical does he not
does he burp the zap version nuclear
power station does he not these become
absolutely critical because the collapse
of Russian military defeat in war often
signals the collapse of a regime for
people like the KGB or the FSB whatever
they're calling themselves not with the
FSB
um they do not distinguish between the
collapse of the state and collapse of
the regime so the collapse of the regime
and the collapse of the state they're
not identical but they're much closer
than it would be in our country so if
you don't go back to take the last Wars
of the last 200 years that the Russians
have fought minus the Napoleonic War
that they won and minus World War II
that they won pretty much every other
War they've lost and every other War has
then resulted in the collapse or the
significant reform of the Russian state
so the Crimean War resulted in the end
of serfdom the Russia Japanese war
resulted in the 1905 Revolution we know
that the horrors of World War One
resulted in the disasters the appalling
disasters of the Bolshevik Revolution
The Finnish War could have gone very
badly wrong in 1940 and the Afghan war
Herald at the end of the Soviet Union so
when this war is lost by the Russian
State then we have to start asking
ourselves how desperate will Putin be
and what will happen internally to
Russia and I mean I've got for the
Russia appg for folks who are interested
we have Leonid volkov coming to talk to
us on Wednesday morning who's Nevada's
chief of staff and he will start talking
about what is the potential for the
collapse of the Russian state so there
are some clearly some very very uh
significant decisions internally Putin
has arrested murdered killed off
imprisoned many of his opponents most
noticeably now navalny who may or may
not be slowly is a health worsening in
the penal colony that he's in I think
he's doing nine years
so he doesn't have pressure from the
Democratic block what Putin does have
pressure from is two groups and it's
worthwhile paying attention to both one
is the Nationalist fascist military
blogger community and these are the
people who've been very vocal and
actually most importantly these are the
people who've allowed to have been they
are allowed by the state to be very
vocal because they were significant
supporters of the war and they if you
read their half a million strong
followers on Telegram and sites like
this they are now despairing and they
are calling for firmer action tougher
action some of these public figures like
uh
um uh preguin who runs the vagular
mercenary group and the and the Chechen
head his name I'm temporarily forgotten
these people are also outliers and
attacking bits of the military various
generals who displeased them the Russian
Ministry of Defense so there is a
problem building up the Nationalist
fascist Community within Russia there is
also a problem building up with the um
wives and mothers part partners of
soldiers killed and injured now we know
in the Afghan war that soldiers mothers
a wonderful group I met them on many
occasions a very moving bunch of people
who just you know fought for their
memory of their kids it was really sad
to see
um there's a hundred thousand Russian
dead that means well I'm seriously
injured probably pushing a hundred
thousand that means there are a hundred
thousand wives and partners and
girlfriends occasionally boyfriends and
mums and dads and that is a significant
potential audience and what hasn't
happened is that the new soldiers mums
and soldiers wives they have not made
common cause with either Democratic
faction which is pretty much
non-existent in Russia and they haven't
yet made common cause with the
Nationalist fascist blogger Group which
I think will be difficult but those are
the two groups and I think Putin will
probably be looking at most nervously so
just to sum up and thank you very much
indeed for for letting me speak for so
long
um I think we have to start thinking
about the end game because the end game
will probably start happening in the
spring then we have to start thinking
about about what will happen with
nuclear decision points then we have to
start thinking about potentially the
failure of Russia and what the disaster
of a chaotic nuclear-powered Russia
looks like so there is much to do for
the government I congratulated in almost
all that it's done I would just say I
think a bit more integration across
government departments is always needed
and I still don't have that and I would
just when it comes to the diplomacy and
I asked the foreign secretary about this
earlier
the the US and the UK have the best
diplomatic networks in the developing
World Ukraine has very very few networks
in the developing World modest anyway
but certainly by our comparison I think
there is much more that we can be doing
for the US and the UK doing systemically
systemically across Asia across Africa
to make sure we partner with the
Ukrainian so they can make their case
because either those nations are nations
that are receiving grain from the
ukrainians and they want to know where
that grain is and we have to make we
have to ensure that they note the
Russians who are the problem here not
the ukrainians but also these are the
people who are most neutral to what the
Russians are doing and what we have to
do is start to get them on side and get
that Community built and in the week on
Thursday on Wednesday evening we are
there's a magnitsky Awards in memory of
sergeymanitsuki beaten to death 13 year
ago 13 years ago on Wednesday by agents
of the Russian State because he was
exposed trying to investigate a 250
million pound Russian dollar fraud and
we remember people like magnitsky but we
also remember many of those human rights
activists and it would be great to see
more non-aligned and neutral countries
countries and countries in Asia and
Africa bringing in their own magnitsky
laws so that they can start Prosecuting
these bad people whether in Russia
whether they're in Iran or whether
indeed they're in China but that's a
discussion for another day thank
yourself
they're a champion uh thank you Mr
Deputy speaker and can I also thank my
honorable friend from the Isle of Wight
who always speaks in such a a measured
and informative tone and I always learn
from listening to him thank you
pretty good we've seen Horrors taking
place in Ukraine throughout this year
but sadly there has been humanitarian
need in the region for so much longer in
2014 Russian annexation of Crimea
heavily affected the east of Ukraine
since Putin's a legal War began in
February it has led to an explosion in
humanitarian need and Ukraine enduring
mass human rights violations the UN
office of humanitarian Affairs estimates
that there are a staggering
17.7 million people in need of
humanitarian assistance and an estimated
6.24 million people internally displaced
within Ukraine
the human rights monitoring mission in
Ukraine estimates at least 16
150 civilian casualties with a majority
in the East but stress is the true
figure is likely to be very much higher
evident violations of international
humanitarian law have taken place with
Russian forces clearly targeting
civilian infrastructure as we've seen
with the bombing of children's
playgrounds and supermarkets
Russian forces of hidden landmines
across the country restricting refugees
ability to leave through humanitarian
corridors and complicating access for
Aid workers
chair of the international defense
committee the former chair of the
Foreign Affairs committee and I wrote
jointly to the former prime minister in
March to highlight these issues and I
continue to urge the current prime
minister to ensure organizations like
the Halo trust and mines Advisory Group
receive the funds that they need to
clear Minds on the ground
the current picture is extremely Bleak
but within winter fast approaching it's
more crucial than ever that Aid reaches
people who desperately need it
in December the daytime temperature
rarely reaches above zero degrees in
Kiev so generators blankets and warm
clothes are absolutely essential
women and girls are being
disproportionately affected by conflict
with the UN reporting that girls are at
an increased risk of child marriage and
being forced to leave school as a result
of their families simply trying to
survive
the UK has pledged 220 million in
humanitarian assistance to Ukraine since
the conflict began
but I continue to express my concerns
that this Aid is not being dispersed
quickly enough
in his response can the minister
guarantee that Aid is reaching local
charities and being distributed in the
most effective ways possible
the conflict has been marked by mass
humanitarian rights violations by
Russian forces including the widespread
despicable use of sexual violence as a
weapon of War
in October the un independent
International Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine published damning evidence of
war crimes with Russian forces
responsible for the vast vast majority
of those
this includes the execution of civilians
consistent accounts of torture and ill
treatment and the use of sexual violence
against women and children
the commission concluded that these
violations continue to have a
devastating effect for victims and
survivors who emphasize the essential
role of justice and accountability
of the many human rights abuses several
notable examples include the massacre in
butcher during which civilians were
rounded up by Russian troops for
execution
the siege of Mario Paul when Russian
forces encircled the city preventing
humanitarian supplies being accessible
and bombing a maternity hospital
and reports of rape and torture during
the Russian occupation of ism
those responsible for countless and
horrifying tribes must be held
accountable and there must be zero
impunity for war crimes committed during
the conflict
the events in Ukraine have pulled the
importance of a rigorous approach to
atrocity prevention into sharp Focus we
cannot allow such violations of human
rights to occur on this skill on this
scale both within and outside of
conflict
my committee recently published a report
on preventing future Mass atrocities
around the world highlighting the need
for the UK to develop an atrocity
prevention strategy I urge the minister
to listen to my committee's report and
take urgent action to prevent further
atrocities taking place we cannot
underestimate the value of a strong
position taken by the International
Community on war crimes with those who
have committed crimes being sufficiently
held to account
victims and survivors deserve our
support in supporting Justice and
ensuring these contemptible crimes
cannot go on any longer
the UK support in Ukraine has been
crucial since the invasion took place
but the government must ensure that we
provide joined up responses to the
humanitarian situation in Ukraine and
prioritize local charities receiving
assistance wherever possible we cannot
step away
thank you thank you very much Dr Ben
Spencer thank you Mr Deputy speaker and
for my contribution to space I'm going
to talk about support for refugees and
it's always a great pleasure to follow
the member honorable opposite for
Rotherham and develop on some of her
points that she made so powerful about
the humanitarian response which I'm
going to talk to about the about the
local response and it's
it's incredible to believe that it's
been almost this entire year that we've
watched the Horrors
uh unfolding in Ukraine Unleashed by
Putin and this absolutely awful war and
senseless Bloodshed and violence
and what we've seen in my community is
the incredible response for moral
constituents across the country and
particularly so in runabead and
weybridge where
we have opened up our hearts and our
homes to the plight of of refugees and I
think that's something quite special
because I think it's nothing perhaps
more personal
in terms of response and support that so
many people are given open up their own
homes
to house and support refugees from
Ukraine I think it's something that we
should be very proud of we've got the
alongside the big stuff the incredible
International Leadership that was shown
in terms of sanctions in terms of
bringing forward a coalition to support
ukrainians in terms of military
technology and kit and training I think
the the domestic rather it's really
small stuff but necessarily somewhat
more most powerful supports I think
we've given is to open up our homes in
support of refugees and I want to give a
huge thank you to everyone in my
constituency
who's done that I'm sure many members
equally have thanked their constituents
and across the country in terms of
support
um that's been given
of course I thank you I think my
honorable friend for giving way on this
point
um just to Echo his comments in in
Watford we've had an incredible out
um burst of love and care for Ukrainian
uh people who are over here in
particular I just wanted to mention
yesterday in Saint Mary's Church as part
of remembrance we had a lady from the uh
from the group there also supported by
Luther blissett the Watford footballer
and Legend England Legend and his
partner Lauren where the lady gave this
beautiful Ukrainian poem at sir Mary's
Church from the pulpit and it was just
an incredible moment to bring home the
loss that she has being here of her
family back home but also the Incredible
strength that those people are showing
by being here and supporting from afar
so I just wanted to Echo those points
thank you
well I thank my honorable friend um
Watford for his um his intervention and
it but you know it it builds on the
points I was about to make in terms of
paying tribute to particular individuals
and groups now
it's always very indigenous to do this
because there's so many people to single
out so many groups to thank in terms of
support doing but I'm gonna I just wanna
raise just um four areas of
microcitruency which I think deserve
particular special attention in amongst
the work that so many individuals and
Community groups are doing one is the
revive Cafe in chertsey which has a
morning uh coffee morning for refugees
um one of the key players in this is a
lady called Lizzie Weyland and who's a
member of the the beacon Church in which
um this Cafe is hosted and they they
give incredible support to people
locally I also want to um draw the house
attention to Alessia Scully and
counciloratory suit who says of
waybridge friends of Ukraine who've been
again pivotal in leading support in
weybridge alongside the elmbridge can
and the way Bridge Community hub
uh we also have a lady called Alina
Melnick who is a refugee herself from
Ukraine who now works uh in running me
borrow Council helping with translation
um for Ukrainian refugees and I'd like
to thank my uh team in my office who
have been incredible in supporting
people in the process of the visa
application scheme and many pieces of
casework with regarding to supporting
refugees uh once they've moved into my
constituency of running medium weybridge
and building on that Spirit I'd like to
finish up in terms of my thanks by
thanking the right restaurant Bishop
Kevin Kenneth novakowski who is from the
Ukrainian Catholic eparchy of the Holy
Family in London who came to speak
um to communist groups my constituents
last week now I don't know if members
have heard him speak but it is he is
incredible incredible it is probably
without that one of the the best
community speech events I've ever been
to where he spoke about he's been center
of the the refugee response from the
start and he spoke about the support he
set up he's given Lessons Learned
um a cautious commentary on what he sees
in the future and there were two points
that really
sent a chill I think uh what what was a
chill one was when was I so um as part
of a speech and I hope it reminds me I'm
mentioning one was when in the visitor
of Ukraine recently he went to a school
and one of the school children I think
it was a little boy come up to him very
excited to see him and said come come
you've got to see a bomb shelter
it's really cool you've got to see a
bomb shelter
that's what I sent a chill I thought it
in a sense it's also quite sweet
because it's it just shows the
resilience of children and you know the
excitement of you know how life changes
and life suggests in the context of
conflict
and another thing that he mentioned
during his talk
was Reflections on when when people can
stop thinking about forgiveness
where we are now
I think that's very difficult to
contemplate
but of course everyone ends
things move on and one of the things
that we were talking about today which I
think is quite important is the
rebuilding of Ukraine
what peace looks like going forwards now
as I say I I cautiously say just the
house because I think it's a very
difficult statement to make right now
where we are and the pain that
everyone's suffering but again I think
needs perhaps thinking in the early
stages in terms of what is the future
that we want to have was a future we can
start hoping for going forwards as is
awful conflict comes to an end
[Applause]
I think all the people who came to the
event that's our host for my
constituency the community groups the
elected representatives uh people who
supported refugees across my
constituency
um our communities are precious
my communities
are without doubt the thing that makes
really the way Bridge the best place in
Earth
um in my view I'm sure colleagues will
say some of the things about their
constituencies and we need to support
our communities I think we all seem to
recognize just incredible work that they
do and I think the response
of course I'm very grateful indeed I
wasn't intending to intervene in this
debate but I think he's made some very
excellent points I too attended a
meeting of
um Ukrainian family sponsors uh two
weeks ago in in my constituency and I
think perhaps the thing I took away from
there is uh the message that we can
bring back to to government to encourage
government to do more to support and to
encourage our fabulous sponsors to
continue to provide that service in many
cases we're coming to the end of the six
month initial term and in in Warrington
in parts of Warrington
um we have very high levels of um of
Ukrainian families who are thinking
about where they can live next because
the sponsors are having given up six
months thinking about what they do next
as well
um do you does my honorable friend agree
with me that the government can take it
a more active lead on this in terms of
supporting and an encouraging sponsor
families to continue
I thank my friend remember for
Warrington for his intervention because
it's almost as if he he has had
foresight on my speech which I know he
hasn't because but the point I was about
to go on to was around um the challenges
in terms of when those sponsor Refugee
relationships break down I just just
finished my my last Point regarding
communities and then I'll I'll come on
to that section my last Point uh was
essentially that we we have to really we
must all cherish our communities and the
support we're giving
um because otherwise I think there's
something very special if we don't fight
to protect and cherishing and thanking
as part of it we'll lose them uh before
it's too late and I think that's a an
important mechanism I'm sure we'll we'll
all share
um so yes uh the point is my final point
that I wanted to make is sadly for a few
months now we've been hearing in my
constituency of breakdowns and
relationship between
um sponsoring refugee
this is getting
um more concerning as we approach
Christmas I think a lot of people uh
when very generously they offered to
take part in the scheme saurus is only a
six-month commitment
um and I think it's important to
recognize you know those who can
continue for six months fantastic those
who can't fantastic for helping out you
know and I think there should be no
animus in terms of what happens and you
know people who can't or feel they can't
continue uh beyond the the initial six
months
my my running meet for a council I've
had many conversations with um their
leader
um councilor Tom Gracie and the CEO
regarding concerns about the matching
process and some refugees aren't able to
be rematched and runny Mead
is going to give them homelessness
support essentially so
um they will they will help re-house
refugees locally who can't who can't be
rematched now of course the concern
there is that's going to put an
additional burden onto local authorities
and I know the government's been very
generous in the support to local
authorities but nevertheless
um that will be a different challenge
particularly in the constituencies such
as mine where availability of affordable
housing affordable rents is very much on
a premium and the the question I have
um to the government to the minister is
in those cases where there's a refugee
where the sponsorship has broken down or
they can't be rematched and the state
takes on the role in terms of
effectively sponsoring them through
homelessness provision
bearing your mind into the homes for
Ukraine's scheme as currently stands the
sponsor gets a monthly payment of about
350 quid when the state then takes over
effectively a state sponsorship role
could it be looked at the local
Authority getting that sponsorship
payment in lieu of the sponsor who would
have done so in the first place because
that seems to be as a a cost neutral in
effect provision something which is
quite a premium
um at the moment as always in terms of
supporting local authorities where
that's broken down so it's not under
pressure in terms of homeless provision
thank you I I guess it's before I before
I said
I I'm really glad that um The Honorable
member has raised this point because
it's a key one and I wonder if he's also
aware that currently it seems the home
office is funding schemes like this from
Oda the foreign aid money but they're
only able to attribute that for the
first year so I'm very concerned that
come February all of the support that
we're able to give to Ukrainian refugees
here is going to come to an end and I'm
very interested to see if the minister
has any information that he can share
with that about if the treasury will
actually step up and fund those people
from that point forward thank you
I thank the animal member opposite for
invention I mean looking back over the
past year had the incredible support
that were given to ukrainians at all
levels you know I'm absolutely confident
that the government will go forwards and
making sure that we are we are doing
um their parts but equally I would be
very interested to know as well in terms
of what are the specific plans in terms
of how that looks going forward given
unfortunately where we are at the moment
it seems that this is going to be a
substantially long war is going to be
displaced people for a long period of
time and so to hear what the the medium
term long-term transition plans would be
will be very interesting thank you
thank you Mr Deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to an honor really to follow
the member from Runnymede and
weighbridge and such wonderful ideas
that have come from himself and my
friend and brim Rotherham who sits at my
side a great pleasure to follow both of
them the many excellent contributions
here today I am sure we are recognized
the remarkable Ukrainian
counteroffensives taking place
particularly in her son to see towns and
Villages people being liberated by
Cranium forces this is see the children
inching out of their hiding places
families reunited is deeply moving and a
testament to the courage and resilience
of the wonderful Ukrainian people
Putin's near nuclear and dirty bomb
rhetoric is designed to distract from
his losses as well as his efforts to
intimidate and divide the West
the best way we can see of any
escalation in the rhetoric is through
the provision of long-term plant of
support for Ukraine for as long as it
takes
with Putin in his gang using energy as a
weapon it is essential that Europe
sticks together and holds our course in
supporting Ukraine standing up to Putin
working to maintain public support for
Ukraine at home and abroad
now is not the time for diplomatic
squabbles with our allies and Neighbors
we must support Ukraine for the long
term Way Beyond 2023 it will be needed
the government should not search it
should set aside individual
announcements and instead set out a
clear strategy in concern with our
allies and Ukraine over long-term
military economic diplomatic support and
the rebuilding of all the infrastructure
the Civic and other Charities and the
volunteers helping those people to build
their lives again
so that we can help ensure Putin's
Invasion really does end in Failure
make no mistake Ukraine is fighting this
war for our assured values of freedom
and democracy we must never ever forget
that the fighting Nations and Nations
War here
we owe so much to Ukraine to the people
to the leadership there we owe so much
to our own forces and their families
their suffered they worry about them
whilst they're out in that country
our support needs to be seen to match
their understanding commitment and
suffering we must thank them all we must
never ever forget them and we must be
there till the end do we see these
people living their life worth living
again remember
thank you um Mr Deputy speaker it's a
great privilege to follow such
remarkable contributions here today and
it's been especially heartwarming to
hear from those members who have talked
about those sponsors of Ukrainian
refugees because I think not just across
this house but across this country there
is a shared sense that the brave men and
women of the Ukrainian armed forces are
fighting for Freedom they are fighting
for our values and they are fighting to
ensure that our values do not perish on
the continent of Europe
there are those and we've heard them in
the American elections Mr Deputy speaker
who are beginning to argue that now
advances are being made and now Ukraine
has captured back about half of the
territory taken by the Russian Invaders
now is the time to somehow let up now is
the time to sue for peace now is the
time to question whether we are
supplying uh too much to the Ukrainian
Armed Forces these voices must be shut
down as fast as quickly as possible now
that we have Ukrainian forces on the
West Bank of the nipro river it is now
possible for us to begin for the
Ukrainian Armed Forces to begin
targeting the supply lines into Crimea
and that means Crimea suddenly comes
into the crosshairs and it is now
possible for us to think realistically
about a battle of the Black Sea in the
months ahead so there are three thoughts
I want to offer to this debate one about
the military options and two about the
political options that I would be
grateful for the minister to take into
account when he winds up the debate at
the end of this evening Mr Deputy
speaker
first militarily as a former General Ben
Hodges argued at the weekend
it is now possible for Ukrainian forces
not simply to hit the lines of control
into Ukraine with high mile systems that
they have from the West Bank of the
nepro river but if we gave them longer
range attackums missiles actually it
would be possible to extend the Ambit of
those fires into the Black Sea and that
would begin to allow attacks on Russian
Navy assets from which let's not forget
let's not forget they have been firing
caliber cruise missiles at the Ukrainian
infrastructure in water and electricity
that is putting such pressure on morale
that we've heard about this evening now
here the two America and I believe it's
a position that NATO has taken has said
that those longer range fires are off
the table
uh we've heard from the Americans that
attackers missiles because they've got a
range of 300 kilometers uh could be
fired directly into Russia and therefore
they won't be supplied to Ukrainian
armed forces and therefore we are not
equipping Ukrainian Armed Forces with
the full capabilities which we have to
offer now given the threat that we know
is coming from Russia given the threat
that we know is posed from the Russian
Navy and the Black Sea surely now is the
time to take away that red line and
actually make available to the Ukrainian
Armed Forces a much wider supply of
Weaponry so that they can actually begin
to double down on the advantage that
their courage has brought them with so
much uh blood and treasure over the last
few months of this year
second Mr Deputy speaker we know that
it's not just about projectiles it is
also about politics and I think there is
a lesson to be learned from the way in
which we brought molotovics to the
negotiating table uh during the the last
Yugoslavia war and it was very simple we
stated in terms that there would be
almost an infinite supply of weapons to
back the forces of goodness until
molotovic signed up to certain terms and
came to the negotiating table at that
point most of it's knew that there was
no Escape he knew the bombardment would
continue until he folded his cards and
so sure enough he folded his cards and
he came to the table and the dating
Accords with what followed surely that
is a lesson that we should learn from
surely now is the time where we don't
just say Putin must lead Russia must
fail the ukrainians must Prevail surely
now is the time in which we set out in
terms what we see as the conditions
which we are determined to see met and
until they are met there will be an
infinite supply of weapons from us as
the Arsenal of Hope in this great
conflict and those terms are very simple
they are safe Skies wide blue safe Skies
across 100 of Ukraine second 100
decolonization of Russian forces from
the territory of Ukraine on 1991 borders
Russia must be removed from every
of Ukrainian land third we must
prosecute Russia for the crime of
aggression there are precedents for this
in international law we know how to do
it the case is very clear we should be
making very clear to Putin that that
prosecution will now come fourth we
should be prosecuting individuals for
the war crimes that they are guilty of
not just in Buca but across the
territory of that black and blood-failed
Earth that Russia uh has uh invaded and
finally we must make sure that there is
a full exchange of prisoners and
repatriation of up to two million people
uh who have been moved by the Russians
uh from Ukraine their Homeland into
various parts of Russia now we know that
these are the five basic demands of
Ukrainian leaders because many of us
were in the presidential Palace in Kiev
when we heard it from president zelenski
so why it is that the foreign secretary
the Secretary of State for defense uh
perhaps even the Prime Minister why they
cannot set out there is going to be an
infinite resupply of weapons until these
terms are met I don't understand why we
are not making that crystal clear to
President Putin and to the people around
President Putin and to the men and women
of the Russian army who are already
fairly mutinous we must make it clear
that we're not going away we're not
backtracking we're not retreating we are
there with the Ukrainian people in their
Armed Forces until every single one of
those five objectives uh is met
the final thing that we should be doing
Mr Deputy speaker is increasing the
political pressure on Putin and those
around him I completely agree with 100
of what the honorable member for
Huntington uh said to the house uh this
evening but I would actually uh go
further we need to ask ourselves in this
house today why is it that we are not
prescribing the United party of Russia
as a terrorist organization are we
seriously saying here in this house that
the United party of Russia is somehow
better cleaner than Hamas or Hezbollah
or The Basque separatist organization
ETA these are all political
organizations whether it's whether
capital P or a lowercase p i don't care
these are political organizations and we
prescribe them for the terrorist
organizations that they are so why are
we not taking the United party of Russia
through that process and why are we not
challenging every single member of that
party to leave it and leave it now I
give ways to honorable member
legislature so I totally agree with what
the right honorable gentleman's saying I
believe that the Prime Minister referred
to Russia as a rogue state only today or
yesterday and the the uh the uh
consequence of that one would have
thought would be
exactly what he's saying absolutely
would have thought of that because there
is no excuse not to think that and but
when we put this point to the foreign
secretary when he came before the
Foreign Affairs uh select committee uh
this afternoon he didn't rule it off the
table he didn't take it off the table
but nor did he give the committee a
timetable for that action and The
Honorable member is right because not
only should we be prescribing the United
party of Russia for the terrorist
organization it is we should be
designating Russia as a state sponsor of
terrorism this is
um an appellation uh that we have
plonked on the government and the state
of Iran since I believe the early 1990s
we actually know already even before the
invasion of Ukraine that there was a
good case for it because Russia is a
sanctuary for the Russian imperial
movement which is an organization which
is designated by the United States as a
terrorist organization Russia has been
providing a safe harbor for that
designated terrorist organization for
some years so why are we not not going
to commence now the business of
designating Russia as a terrorist as a
terrorist State sponsor
kinds of implications not least one of
the suggestions that I think the
honorable member for Huntingdon was
aiming at which is to begin Banning
tourist visas from Russia uh immediately
I know that there will always be people
in this house who say well we can't make
go to war with the Russian people we've
got to you know accept that there are
good people amongst those tourists and I
hear all of that but look if we are
serious about making sure that Russia is
not able to do this again then we have
to make clear to the Russian people the
way in which we see the sins of their
nation and frankly make it crystal clear
that they must act within their country
to deliver a different kind of
leadership in the years to come the
final piece of the puzzle of course is
sanctions and I hope that we will be
able to have a longer debate about this
when the economic crime Bill comes back
for the report stage but it's obviously
ludicrous that the minister and his
colleagues have Frozen a 45 million
dollar yacht down the road from here
into Catherine stock the Phi and there
it is sitting there uh as yet still
frozen but unseased we heard today that
Mr abramovich's money from his sale of
his football club has still not actually
made it to Ukraine to begin in
reconstruction when are these things
going to happen it is time that we not
simply froze assets we start we start
seizing the assets and re-channeling
that money into the supply of Ukraine
and its reconstruction Mr Deputy speaker
let me just finish with a simple message
um which is this we uh in this continent
of in this homeland of Europe of ours we
learned a long time ago in international
relations from the approach the
Athenians took to the poor malias uh
they were the people confronted several
thousand years ago with the message that
might somehow makes right that is not
something that we subscribe to in this
country this is a country that stands up
to bullies and when we see others
like-minded Souls standing up to bullies
like Putin our job is to back them every
inch of the way
final speech before the wind up switch
it forward thank you Mr Deputy speaker
and and what a very powerful speech to
have to follow from the right honorable
member for Hodge Hill but I Echo the um
the comment that was made earlier from
The Honorable member for Rotherham this
is a very being a very informative
debate
um and uh and in particular I found the
contributions of um The Honorable
members the Isle of Wight Huntington and
Plymouth Saturn in particular really
worthwhile listening the falling back of
the Russian army from her son in recent
weeks and days presents us with an
opportunity to reflect on what the UK
and its allies intend will be achieved
by our support for Ukraine
today Town position has simply been that
we reiterate our moral and material
support and quite right too but there
have been voices in NATO and here in the
UK who since the spring been urging us
to have aims that are independent of
those of the government of Ukraine
and I'm strongly of the view that as
2022 draws to a close
we should not have stated aliens that
differ from those of the government in
Kiev
the government in Moscow is determined
to paint the wall as one that Putin did
not seek
when addressing the Russian people and
extending the mobilization of Russian
citizens the Russian government seeks to
stimulate fear of the West
it's been said several times this
evening that the UK supports Ukraine
because of our outrage at the invasion
in the 21st century of a sovereign state
that posed no threat to its neighbors
but an additional reason why the UK's
aims and Ukraine's aims are indivisible
is to undermine Russia's claim that this
is a proxy war which NATO is using
Ukraine to fight on its behalf
Lord David Richards of Hearst monzu has
argued that the UK and its NATO allies
should have a grand strategic War aim
with a defined end state
he said in April that without such a
well-defined end State I quote there is
a risk for events overtake Us in the way
that happened in 1914.
but there are some fundamental
differences between now and 1914.
in 1914 the UK intervened directly in
support of Belgium and deployed the
British expeditionary Force
by contrast NATO governments have been
at pains to demonstrate our restraint by
supplying Ukraine with material
while avoiding direct involvement of our
Armed Forces Personnel in the conflict
there are perhaps some stronger
parallels between the situation that we
see today and the one that arose in 1916
it had been rumored in 1916 that some in
the United States were seeking to engage
Germany and our Anton powers in dialogue
with a view to peace
this is a time when the aggressor was
still in possession of territory that it
had acquired directly as a result of its
aggression
Britain's then Secretary of State for
war the liberal Minister David Lloyd
George pointed out at that time that
Britain and its allies were only just
beginning to see some successes and that
negotiating a compromise at that time
would serve only to reward aggression
Lloyd George talked about the need to
ensure that military despotism is broken
Beyond repair
last week it was suggested in the press
that some voices in the United States
might have been leaning on Ukraine to
alter its objectives U.S chairman The
Joint Chiefs of Staff General Mark Riley
said we've seen the Ukrainian military
fight the Russian military to a
standstill
now what the future holds is not known
with any degree of certainty but we
think there are some possibilities here
for diplomatic Solutions
when questioned the the U.S national
security adviser Jake Sullivan said the
U.S is not pressuring Ukraine and we're
not insisting on things with Ukraine
I think we should just stand back and
reflect that Baron Richards and general
Miley have or or are the professional
heads of their Armed Forces so
they've seen enough of War to know that
it's a blunt instrument that it's
unpredictable and is inferior in most
ways to diplomacy
I think they and others are entirely
right constantly to ask questions about
the NATO Grand strategy and whether we
might be able to articulate our own end
state or see a diplomatic way out
and on this point I think
um I disagree with the right honorable
member for Hodge Hill that safe Skies
implemented by way of uh no-fly zones
policed by NATO would be the right thing
while that was something Ukraine called
for early in the war I was with him Ian
Keith when we heard about the sorts of
Demands that were being articulated by
Ukraine today and I would agree with him
that removing Russia from all of
Ukrainian territory was much more along
the lines of what's being called for
today than anything
I too don't believe that there can be a
new so police no-fly zone but what I do
believe is that there can be much
greater supply of air defense weapons
that we have and Ukraine needs
I think the right honorable member for
correcting my understanding
I talked last week to a Ukrainian MP
from the sister party of the liberal
Democrats and he talked about how we in
the west have failed in the last two or
three decades to fully understand that
the Soviet Union uh was an Empire he
suggested that we never fully
appreciated that there was not consent
for states to belong to the USSR in the
first place and that it had been a
Russian KGB LED Empire all along which
some in Russia would like to see
recreated
these are some reasons why the West
should not at this time seek to have
aims that differ from those of the
democratically elected government of
Ukraine
instead
I would urge that we act solely in
support of our Ukrainian Ally because in
the 21st century there's no case for the
logic articulated by Catherine the Great
that I have no way to defend my borders
but to extend them
thank you Mr Deputy speaker wind up
Stephen douty yeah
uh thank you Mr Deputy speaker and I'd
like to thank colleagues from across the
house for their contributions to today's
debate I think we've had some really
fantastic uh Reflections I also want to
add my thanks at the start of the debate
to all of the United Kingdom troops and
indeed officials who are playing such a
critical role in supporting Ukraine uh
particularly as we remember the
sacrifices of past Generations in
remembrance this weekend
um the uh honorable from Huntington who
was in in Kiev with me a few weeks ago I
thought made some very very important
points about the uh the crimes of the
Russian regime go much wider than Putin
and I thought particularly of the
children's commissioner who's been
justifying the separation and kidnap
effectivity of Ukrainian children also
some very important points about the
seizure and repurposing of assets we
heard a powerful speech from the
spokesperson for the SMP and again
demonstrating the unity of support
across this house from all parties uh
The Honorable friend from the Isle of
Wight always makes a very important
points and I think his Reflections on
the same brutal tactics that we saw in
in Syria targeting of hospitals and
others and also his thoughtful remarks
on the next stage as the war and use of
our diplomatic networks were very well
put my honorable friend from Rotherham I
think made some very important points
about mines and unexploded ordinance the
huge challenge that comes with that and
the huge humanitarian need that is there
plus the huge human human rights
violations that we are seeing tragically
revealed with each Advance
um there are women for running between
waybridge I think spoke powerfully of
the work in our own communities and the
support that's being given I've indeed
seen that of course in my own
constituency in Cardiff Southampton New
Community Support Center opening up in
butteown and regular demonstrations and
protests ensuring that people remain
engaged with the challenges which are
going to continue tragically for some uh
time and important that we keep on the
agenda and my honorable friend Francis
and Helen's South and Western
um I thought powerfully about the scenes
we've seen in the last few days in her
son and the need for the UK to have a
long-term plan for as long as is needed
and indeed that was reflected very much
in their remarks of Marvel friendly
friend from Birmingham Hodge Hill who
rightly said that we must shut down the
siren narratives
um from what you know we call them
gently the Putin Whisperers
um whether that's in the U.S or indeed
in our other allies and again
emphasizing the need for long-term
commitments and long-term
um supplies uh for as long as is needed
it was a very powerfully made uh point
and indeed um the comments from the
liberal Democrat spokesperson from
Tifton and homerton and the importance
of aligning with the requests and
demands of the Ukrainian government and
indeed some other thoughtful Reflections
on history so I think we've had a very
very useful uh debate uh today Mr Deputy
speaker and I think the proceedings show
again a true reflection on Britain's
solidarity with the people of Ukraine
our Collective commitment to Ukrainian
freedom and indeed our unwavering uh
unity in opposition to this illegal War
indeed these were points that myself and
indeed my honorable Friends The Shadow
defense secretary and Shadow foreign
secretary made on our visit to Nato this
week not only the important our
continued support for Ukraine but our
continued support for our NATO allies in
the face of the threats that we Face we
are now over eight months into a war
that Putin expected to be over in days
and he said we are here and the
incredible scenes I think that we've
seen in the last few days in her son
lifting thousands from the Yoke of
Russian occupation and dealing a
devastating blow to Putin with the price
of his miscalculations becoming ever
more apparent to his people and indeed
the scenes today we've seen a president
zelenski there in the center of her son
I think absolutely remarkable obviously
a very dangerous situation but I think
showing a testament to his uh bravery
and determination from the very top and
that's one thing that I saw in Ukraine
from the bottom to the top the
termination of the entire country to
stand together in the face of this
absolute barbarous activity from the
Russian regime and I'm sure that the
whole house will agree that although the
facades of Putin's invulnerability is
beginning to dissipate as the war Falls
the war Falls in to further disarray
this is of course no time for
complacency because we've all seen the
critical infrastructure that's been
destroyed the damage that has been done
and despite the huge significance of
this Victory with Communications
electricity water and energy utilities
decimated and indeed he has traps off
and left by the occupiers the days ahead
will be challenging for the people of
Curson and indeed other regions that are
liberated we also know that Russian
shells will tragically continue to fall
on the city and airstrikes will continue
to affect Ukraine's Urban centers in in
retaliation undoubtedly for this defeat
and the days and weeks ahead will be
critical in setting the future course of
this war and indeed I saw for myself the
damage on the outskirts of of Kiev on
the on the visit
um that we we undertook and again draw
attention to my Declaration on that on
that matter
um I wanted to ask um the minister a
number of questions firstly if you could
say a little bit more about the support
that is being provided
um to UK regard starting demining and
the removal of unexploded Ordnance so
it's a question that came up in a number
of the contributions
um and I know that we've played a
critical role so far but this is going
to be a very very long
um job secondly I wondered if he could
say we had many many comments um in the
debate today about the risks of of siren
narratives of Ukraine fatigue creeping
in to the domestic politics of our
friends and allies around the world and
of course we saw some of those
narratives before the U.S midterms from
some elements of the Republicans and
indeed we're seeing those in some other
countries too and of course we've seen
Wagner group
um not only committing horrific
atrocities but also being very clear
about what they intend in terms of
disinformation and undermining our
democracies and precaution
um uh said himself and I quote we have
interfered we are interfering and we
will continue to interfere carefully so
accurately surgically and in our own way
as we know how to do in terms of
disinformation and misinformation
and of course they targeted a number of
those key uh races in the United States
that are quite uh open about for
attempting to do that and we know what
they've done in elections around Europe
so could the minister say a little bit
more about our efforts to counter that
disinformation to ensure the robustness
of our Democratic systems and processes
our media our elections and our
political processes and what steps he's
taking with our allies to ensure that
that robustness is not just in this
country but indeed across our uh Global
alliances and also could you say a
little bit about uh with the G20 taking
place these days with the Prime Minister
there in Bali
um what steps are being taken to ensure
that support amongst our allies and
partners is as Ironclad as it was in
February and that all wings of our
diplomatic Coalition recognize that we
are in this until Ukraine is the Victor
um Deputy speaker I want to also just
um address the uh those attacks on
Ukraine's critical infrastructure and
we've seen um terrible attacks against
energy against water and other areas of
course see the use of Iranian drones as
well and I wondered if you could say a
little bit more about what conversations
uh he has been having well allies and
also with Israel regarding
um The Wider risks and they're posed by
allowing Iran to supply this type of
weapery and to use it and what steps we
can be taking together to counter it
um I'm grateful for his response to my
questions about the generators that we
were providing to Ukraine I understand
that 100 850 have now been provided I
know the comments made by the minister
earlier about support for electricity
generation but what conversations have
ministers had regarding long-term needs
in this regard and what conversations
have we had with UK manufacturers to
ensure there is a joined up approach to
providing power and critical
infrastructure to the people of Ukraine
going forward and I think it's also
worth pointing out Mr Deputy speaker
that Russia's attacks on fuel Depots and
other utilities have released toxins
into the air and groundwater threatening
the environment of Ukraine and indeed
comments made at cop today by the
Ukraine's environment Minister
um he said that 16 million cars in the
UK for two years is the equivalent of
the emissions that have been caused by
Russia's uh actions and so it's not just
the death and destruction that we are
seeing in cities it's also the
environmental degradation and there is
to our climate that they are providing
we've heard a lot that Deputy speaker
today about the repurposing of assets
and compensation indeed there's been a
vote to the United Nations while this
debate has been going on which is made
very clear that United Nations believes
that reparation should be paid and that
there should be mechanisms for ensuring
that compensation is provided to Ukraine
so I wondered if you could say a little
bit about the Diplomatic efforts in that
regard and how he sees that
um going forward Mr Deputy speaker there
are a lot of other concerns have been
raised today about the domestic supports
and I hope we can have an update soon
from the home office about the homes for
Ukraine scheme and how our support for
refugees is going to continue going
forward and there are many many
unanswered questions and also questions
about practical things many ukrainians
have raised me concerns about drivers
licenses and permits they were
temporarily
um allowed not to have to register and
what conversations does he have with DFT
colleagues um to resolve that issue but
in conclusion a message Deputy speaker
eight months since Putin launched this
illegal War we must remind ourselves of
one inescapable Truth for Ukraine this
is a war of necessity of survival but
for Putin it's a choice a Barbara's
Choice a choice to attempt to erase
Ukraine from the map and to fulfill his
warped Imperial Ambitions and that
distinction must underscore our
continued engagement with allies and
partners in emphasizing why uh holding
firm standing United and sporting
Ukraine is so critical whether that is
uninsuring that food comes out of
Ukraine and that Russia's attempts to
block that are fully stood up against
whether that's in the Diplomatic
coalitions the United Nations whether
that's on sanctions whether that's on
Military and civilian supplies whether
that's on macroeconomic support and
whether that's on the political and
diplomatic coalitions that we build we
must stay the course we are committed on
this side to working with the government
in supporting Ukraine in the difficult
winter ahead and well into the future
for as long as it takes Ukraine must win
and with our support we can ensure that
this Victory ends the Kremlin cycle of
warmongering for good
well thank you very much Mr Deputy
speaker I'm very honored to be able to
wind up today it's been a passionate and
uh very constructive and positive uh to
base I'm very grateful for all uh
contributions uh I'll try and cover off
as many uh points as possible Mr Speaker
in the brief time I have available I was
grateful for the um honorable member for
Plymouth Sutton and devonport for
pointing out that this is this is indeed
day 264 of this brutal and illegal
conflict but of course Putin has
strengthened not weakened the Western
Alliance and I'm grateful for his uh
reassurance of support for for the
government position on on this he he
made some interesting Reflections on the
the utility of operation interflex and
the remarkable training that we're doing
with our allies for our Ukrainian
friends and he pointed out the need for
for resolve and that Resolute is what we
are Mr Deputy speaker he appealed for a
long-term plan I can give him that
assurance that we do have a long-term
plan we've announced that next year we
all match or exceed 2.3 billion pounds
we put into military assistance this
year of course we will underwrite and
Grant in excess of 1.5 billion pounds of
humanitarian and fiscal Aid to our
Ukrainian friends through the World Bank
and the ebrd
um very briefly yes from that point I
thank the minister for giving way we are
obviously we have been using up our own
supplies so as well as giving supplies
to the ukrainians uh can the minister
reassure us that we're being mindful of
our own needs and our own Supply base
here
uh intervention he will have noted that
the uh mdp was on the front bench
earlier on uh and we were discussing
exactly that point and I'm grateful for
that intervention uh The Honorable
gentleman asked for an IR refresh I'm
not going to give a running from
commentary but we should remember that
it was basically proved right the
integrated review we are refreshing it
it's an organic evolving document uh and
and it's in good shape he mentioned
end-law production uh so it's a really
valuable point we are working with
industry to ensure that there is a
pipeline he made a valuable point about
dual use technology I am reassured that
our sanctions Provisions do cover that
but I will look at that Lucy report and
ask my mod colleague to reply to that
I'm in DP because I think that is
probably a very important report he
mentioned war crimes uh two weeks ago I
was in The Hague Mr Deputy speaker
meeting with the chief prosecutor of the
ICC and uh he has got the bit between
his teeth and clearly he's independent
but we will support him institution as
much as we can to hold uh those
Prosecuting war crimes that account for
natural for the reason of natural
justice but also to deter uh any further
possible war crimes he mentioned the
humanitarian crisis that will surely
emerge this winter we are uh pleased to
be providing 220 million pounds of
humanitarian Aid and of course 850
generators uh for uh for the generations
to keep homes warm he mentioned the
defense budget I'm not going to
speculate from the dispatch books about
events on this Thursday but I know he
will be patient uh to hear uh uh exactly
some of the detail that will be laid out
um on on Thursday's budget The Honorable
gentleman from Huntington moving on um
spoke interestingly of his visit to
Ukraine he has some really interesting
Reflections on the nature of Russian
leadership and the fact that no Putin
did not necessarily mean no war and I
thought that was a very interesting way
of looking at it he speculated about
um uh how Putin should be held to
accountable and whether it should be
Putin or Russia and of course he also
spoke about the the the Reconstruction
effort and the funding thereof and I
should remind him that we are very proud
to be holding the Ukraine reconstruction
conference in July next year and given
his long-standing interest in Ukraine I
know he'll uh take a good deal of
interest in that event The Honorable
Jennifer Weston bartonshire uh spoke
movingly about accountability and war
crimes again I restrict my visit to the
ICC in our determination our expectation
that
um that those uh who have prosecutive
war crimes will be held to account he
set the the the this conflict in a very
useful Global concept which I thought
was was very interesting and referred to
Resource terrorism and that's exactly
what it is with regards to the
constraints on the flow of Graham from
the Black Sea he spoke about the
existential nature of uh Ukraine's Noble
struggle and I was very interested to
hear his remarks about the activities
and operations of the pride Brigade and
that was most welcome I was interested
to learn about that and I thank him as
ever for his ongoing support of him and
his party for the uh for the
government's position with regardless
Ukraine my horrible friend from the Isle
of Wight spoke with characteristic
knowledge and insight about the
two-prong approach of the Russian war
machine and serovicin that being the
denipro defensive position on the river
and the use of defensive position on the
river and also they're abhorrent and
entirely outrageous attempt to smash
civilian infrastructure including
hospitals he drew a morbid parallel with
Syria which was which was interesting
but of course deeply worrying and of
course raised the terrifying Specter of
the use of chemical weapons of course he
I think he's right in his judgment that
Putin has bought some time but of course
perhaps uh Mr Deputy speaker perhaps
there is some sort of revolutionary end
game who knows but I thought his
speculation and his various scenarios
that he laid out were interesting and of
course based in a deep knowledge of that
country given his former residence there
he appealed for uh yes blood
I'm very grateful to the minister given
that he recognizes the risk
um of Putin damaging Ukrainian civilian
infrastructure
why does
argue that when we shouldn't be
providing longer range fires to Ukraine
to Ukrainian armed forces in order to
counter that well I I would say all
options remain on the table I would note
that um the the ukrainians have been
Thanks to Western support been uh
terrifically uh effective at taking some
of the ballistic uh barrage down from
from uh in terms of defending their
Skies but of course I'm not a rule on
anything from from the dispatch box if I
can move on to the honorable uh lady for
uh Rotherham the chair of the
International Development Committee she
made a good remark about Halo trust I
can confirm that we continue to support
the Halo trust and they have so far
cleared 16 000 square meters of land
here in the kieval Blaster will continue
to do so we have pledged 220 million
pounds of humanitarian Aid and I can
assure her this is reaching the the
front line as it were in terms of the
people that do need it and we're working
with the United Nations of Red Cross uh
ngos and through at 13.4 million people
have been helped so far with funds
distributed she also mentioned
accountability I draw reference to my
previous remarks about the ICC and she
appealed for a joined up approach which
is uh exactly what we're after and I
have not yet read her report but uh but
I look forward to reading I'm very
grateful for her bringing it up the my
honorable friend from Runnymede and
waybridge made a a moving speech
reflecting on the great compassion shown
by his constituency and refer to the
remarkable way that his constituents had
opened up their hearts and their homes I
think we've every member of this house
will have seen that in their own
constituency I've certainly seen a North
shot yeah and I'm grateful I I second
his uh thanks that he put on record for
the revive Cafe in chertsey and the
weybridge friends of Ukraine and and the
way Bridge Community Hub and he he asked
a technical question about homes for
Ukraine and the extent to which a
provision might be made directly to the
local Authority if it wasn't going via
host families I haven't got an answer
right now but I will ensure that a
colleague from uh Department of leveling
up in communities rights to him but also
the chair of the International
Development uh committee The Honorable
for Saint Helens and South we're very
very briefly
very briefly may I share the points that
honorable members and colleagues and
Friends made across the house about the
need to support Ukrainian refugees in
the long term for as long as they need
to be here but also ask him to reflect
on how we support their mental health is
they deal with crisis from afar and in
particular how government and local
government can support support groups
who are helping so many at the moment
thank you I'm grateful for that
intervention that is well noted and I
also put on record my thanks for the
work he does as a mental health champion
and also for his supports to Ukraine and
our Ukrainian friends in his own
constituency of Watford uh The Honorable
lady for Saint Helens and South Western
spoke uh movingly about uh in an appeal
for solidarity among the allies of
Ukraine and that's exactly what we see
on the Diplomatic front on the military
front and and in terms of reconstruction
I see that very visibly and powerfully
when traveling and talking to allies
right across Europe and I think we are
we are bold in our resolve to see you
this through the right honorable
gentleman for Birmingham hottest Hill
spoke passionately uh and and laid out
three uh very interesting points firstly
with regard to the military Dimension uh
and appeal to to provide long-range
fires as I said I'm not going to rule
anything in or out of a dispatch Port
but of course all options continue to be
under review
um I I appreciated the way he uh uh
described the fact that you the
Ukraine's courage had brought on the
huge advantage and I think that is at
the heart of their successful
prosecution of their counter-attack it's
their it's their courage which has
brought them a significant Advantage he
also referred to the utility of uh the
uh having an infinite supply of arms and
Drew an interesting historical parallel
with milosevic I thought I thought that
was interesting in in terms of the
context of there being an arsenal of
Hope in in terms of the western allies
and I thought that was useful and I'm
grateful he referred to political
pressure and quite abrupt quite
forthrightly challenged the government
to to designate
um uh United Russia party and just
designate Russia as a state sponsor of
Terror that's an interesting proposition
I'm not going to make a pronouncement
about that but I'm grateful for the uh
passionate way in which he's raised
those questions and he also raised some
interesting Tech questions about the
sanctions uh we are we are getting after
not just sanctioning but but also
seizing and ensuring that things like
for example the monies from the sale of
Chelsea football does get those who need
it but I'm grateful for his interest The
Honorable General fertility and Honiton
made an interesting parallel to 1916 and
also gave some really good insights from
his discussions with uh with a Ukrainian
MP poly for which I was most grateful
and he made a very interesting remark
about uh Catherine's a great approach to
her borders which is frankly is worrying
given the Imperial parallels that are
sometimes drawn by the Russian
leadership themselves in conclusion Mr
Deputy speaker The Honorable gentleman
for College of Southern panath uh gave
some good reflections on the the
impressive site of President zielinski
visiting Curson leading from the front
as ever I was very grateful for his
remarks about that and he speaks from a
position of knowledge having visited key
recently uh grateful for his
constructive and positive team as ever
and in brief uh Mr Speaker uh we will
continue to support Halo effort the Halo
trust's effort to continue uh demining
we are working with our lives to counter
disinformation across the region in all
domains and that continues a piece he
appeal for Unity and uh I think we do
have that with our allies you mentioned
drones and Iran's we are getting off of
that with our very aggressive sanctions
policy but we are we'll we'll look at
dual use in that regard very very
briefly of the highest I asked you
specifically had he yet raised that
issue with with Israel
um and also given the rumors that Iran
has been supplying uh medium-range
ballistic missiles as well to Russia to
be stationed in locations capable of
targeting Kiev
I think my understanding is that has but
let me just check and I will write to
The Honorable gentleman I want to be uh
uh
completing my answer he mentioned
generators uh we are we are getting off
uh and 850 have been committed I should
also say that 10 million has today been
committed by the foreign secretary to
the electricity uh rebuilding uh
reconstruction for technical
reconstruction of power generating
capability the first five will be uh
committed today but it's over 10 million
uh fund and he mentioned reparations
again I think that's something that
should be broadly considered but Mr
Speaker if I can just reiterate that we
will not be deterred from supporting
Ukraine and I would just want to draw
members uh attention to the fact that a
good measure of our resilience and the
strength of our alliance is that last
month at the United Nations 143
countries three quarters of the
membership of the United Nations voted
to condemn the outrageous and illegal
and annexation of Ukrainian territory
this was a measure Mr Deputy speaker the
fact that Ukraine is strong because it
has many friends and you and Russia
despite having a very very long border
has very few friends we are proud to
stand with our Ukrainian friends of
Freedom democracy and the sovereignty of
Nations around the world and we will
proudly continue to stand with them
until they are victorious thank you
and on Thursday I was privileged to be
at a Ukraine fundraiser at St Peter's
Church at Wilton Place in London where
it was a very Welsh theme that's why I'm
looking at you Stephen uh with the
London Welsh choir and my good friend
the soprano Rebecca Evans singing as
well it was the Ethereal music for a
just cause and I hope we raise
substantial sums of money
pay tribute to all of those throughout
the country who are helping to raise
funds for the Ukraine cause
the question is that this house is
considered the situation in Ukraine as
many as of that opinions say I
country no I think the eyes have it the
eyes have it
questions that this house do now adjourn
Andy Carter
thank you very much Mr Deputy speaker
and I'm very grateful to have been able
to secure this debate to discuss the
impact of low traffic neighborhoods and
latchford and while I go on to talk
about the Practical and environmental
impact of these initiatives or rather
the lack thereof as I'll explain in the
case of Warrington South I'll be
focusing on my constituents experiences
of the Westy load traffic neighborhood
Zone which was imposed by Warrington
Borough Council on people living and
working in the latchford area of my
constituency earlier this year
my Mr Deputy speaker this is an issue
myself and conservative counselors have
been at odds with labor over for some
time now I've had many meetings with
local residents and business owners
who've told me they are angry and quite
simply fed up with the low traffic Zone
that's been forced on them without
proper consultation and that the council
have failed to listen to their concerns
over the scheme now in explaining the
background of what's been happening in
latchford